hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to cover react
with
redux so with our session today we're
going to go through it's going to cover
why you'd want to use redux when you're
building a react solution
what redux is what are the core
principles of redux
and what are those pillars that drive
what you're doing redux
and then finally what are the pros and
cons of redux and after we've gone
through the powerpoint presentation here
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through and actually do a
demo
of actually using uh redux so you can
actually see
how this would all look so why would you
use redux well
the reason why you want to use redux is
that redux actually understands and
helps manage the state
of an object and redux was introduced
to help address some problems that
you're having with react
so the state for an object stores values
and properties that belong to components
that could potentially change over time
so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network
uh they could be changes to the
re-render of the component in the
browser
and the object could also then
potentially store
multiple properties and then with redux
it actually takes in and actually will
create a you know take a
large application that you could create
with app with a react
and breaks it down to several components
instead of having this
massive number of states you have to
manage
and so every time that you you know an
application will then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the states and
this is a
a really big problem because when you're
like doing that switching back and forth
there is the potential for
applications to be re-rendered which
reduces the efficiency of your
application
and so this is why redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux
is a way to be able to have a
predictable state container for your
javascript applications
they allow you to run your applications
in multiple different environments so
whether it's
a client solution a service solution or
a native app solution
and then more importantly or one of the
key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really
easy to test and so with redux you're
able to manage the state of your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
javascript framework
or library and you can actually then
store the um
the application and the components in a
state
store which makes it easy to be able to
manage the state of your application
so in simple words redux stores all the
state objects in a single store and
organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application
any changes in the state the application
can be described to the store by the
user
and then it notifies any modifications
made to the state of that
application so let's jump into the key
principles of redux and there's three
key areas i want to focus in
so the first one is that redux provides
a single source of truth um and that
source of truth is being able to store
the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single
store and this makes it easier for you
to debug and inspect
components of your application uh also
enables you to be able to persist your
app state for development
and improve fastest development cycles
the second principle is a state is read
only
and that's why you're able to describe
more effectively what's happening
because it is read only and this ensures
that no events like network callbacks
uh would uh create and any issues
with the code and the re-rendering of
your application
and that object actions are become then
just plain objects
and then finally changes are made with
pure functions and so what do we mean by
this so we can actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with
pure reducers and we'll go into a demo
later on to show
you this but a reducer is essentially a
function that accepts
an accumulation value and then it takes
back and returns that
as a new accumulation and this allows
you to have a single source of truth
value
the user can return the new state
objects instead of mutating to a
previous state
the user can start with a single
reducing as the app grows
it can then split off into a smaller
reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions
so let's talk about the pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree
state and there are four key
states there's get state which turns the
current c to the store
and when we actually run the demo later
on you'll be able to see
that we'll be able to open up our
terminal window and be able to
get the state store from our terminal
window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an
action it's the only way to update the
application state
and here we have a action on a button
change
to actually change the state of the
application and then the final two
are subscribe unsubscribe and
these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state
so an action is a plain object that
represents an intention
to change the state so with actions you
have payloads of information that send
data
back and forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data
that can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a type field
that
indicates the type of action that has
been performed
and finally with reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions
sent to the store and so actions only
describe what's happened but don't
describe
the application state change they are
reducer is a function that accepts the
current state and an
action and then returns a new state with
the action performed
and then finally you can use combined
reducers utility
which can then combine reduces in an app
into a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because
nothing is perfect so a
pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store
so there's no confusion over where
you're getting your values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict
outcome redux is more stringent about
how the code is organized this makes it
easier to onboard developers because
there is
a very structured way of writing redux
code
this makes it also then easier for the
initial render
which allows you to make uh your
solution really optimized as an
experience
and then finally developers can track
everything that's going on inside the
app in real time
the cons so one of the big cons is
there's no encapsulation so you're using
redux to test out
the code and the writing of your code
but
the component cells can access data and
they there is potential for security
issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back
to the structured code format it is um
strict in its um setup and it is
memory intensive so with that let's go
in
and look at a demo of using redux to
reformat a react application so in this
demo we're going to use
react to show how redux can work
first thing we want to do is go ahead
and download node.js we're going to go
to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os
and linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version
now there are other versions you can use
but that's one you would want to use
i already have it installed so i just
want to show you how that looks so i'm
just going to go in and put
node version it's going to give me the
version number so that
shows that it's installed and we'll also
use npm which is node package manager
because we'll be using that
validate that it's installed by doing
node mpm-version
okay so we're looking good and we're
going to go ahead and create a folder
um on our desktop um normally you
wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for
an experiment so we're going to call
this one uh redux
react it's going to be taking a react
project
and we're going to show what it looks
like as a standard project and then what
it will look like
as a project that's being taken through
redux so let's just move our cursor to
the correct folder and so we're going to
go to cd redux react
and there we are in add the correct
folder
using our command prompt you use
terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax
and we're going to do create dash react
dash app so we're going to create a
default
react app and then we're going to also
install redux
dash app and these are the two
components that we need to be able to
build out our solution one is
react and it's react.js and the second
is
redux and we hit return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of
both of these applications and install
them
into the folder that we just created on
our desktop
just give that a moment and so it's
installing the
different packages react react dom react
scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so i'm
going to use visual studio code to do
most of our work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms now it is from microsoft but
it is open source
and there's just a ton of stuff here but
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to open up the folder we just created on
our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder which is
going to read the welcome screen we
don't need that anymore
uh you'll see there's some commands we
use we do uh control plus
uh i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um not an exclamation point so
you'll see that in our project folder we
have all of the
files we need for our solution we have
both the
node modules and then the public files
the product files is just the
application itself so over here on the
index.html you see the
index file there and we're going to
actually show what this looks like
inside the
uh as it's broadcast from a web browser
in a moment
now uh we're going to create a very
simple application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both
um uh just standard react and
uh redux react it's the optimization
that's gonna be improved
so we just did npm dash and start it's
gonna take us to localhost call on 3000
give it a moment and then we should get
our floating
uh logo showing that the application's
up and running
up there we are we can go ahead and head
and edit app.js to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into app.js
and we are going to create an
application called new comp
dot js and we actually have some code
that we've already
created that you can download as part of
this application
um so but we're just going to type in
here import react
and then component from
react so i'm
going to pull in our react library and
we also import
connect from
react redux
and that's the package that we're
working in
let's terminate the batch up yes
and then rerun
npm install
save react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for
the uh using the store and reduces in
redux
again the the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution and
this is what redux gives you all right
so we're going to go ahead and we're
going to go in
and type in class new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this state
equals i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app don't forget to
save your work as you go along
and we're just going to apply some
styles let's just make the
apply some font style
make italics
then we're gonna make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
i'm sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
we just have some basic html for where
we're going to place everything we use a
div tag for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call reference this
styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be created dynamically use our
style
i'm going to add in a button
we have a one click action
subscribe
and don't change too many s's
save that
all right save now let's run the script
you're going to have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
okay rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the newscorp js
component into here
byron
font style here
and
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
now playing from use code so we'll
actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code all right
let's
run that npm
start and here we go
refreshes our page so what we've just
created is a
basic standard state object
and oh let's see now
oh yeah this is good now we actually can
show you
that uh we didn't actually write all our
code correctly so let's go back and fix
that
because newport news
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
have a correct export feature here so
that the image
that the everything can be exported
effectively
in import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our uh
problem hey there we are so welcome and
then we have the
standard state object of subscribe to
hit subscribe
and we change the text to thank you for
subscribing okay so let's
kind of go in and modify this now so it
goes from being a standard state object
to one that uses store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job and essentially reset
everything
and we're going to do now is install
redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good and now we want to
start our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to our index file
index.js
and here's our react dom
now we're going to add in contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and we're going to pull in
strict mode okay
juice is not too fine let's go ahead and
define that
so we're going to come over to our
new comp.js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in and
let's map our state to
props equals
state and we're going to do
return
message is state
dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is gonna be our dispatch
and we're gonna type in return
and we have our button change
for dispatch
and we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change let's
turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right and now
we actually connect
as parabolic export and in our
connection i'm going to do
map state props and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and you go ahead and create a new folder
and this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
i'm going to call the store reducer.js
and const initial state
equals this is what the default state
will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and con's new state
and it's going to be an if
action dot type
i'm going to change the message
so here's unused comp
so that's the action there we
pull that so it's identical
and then new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so we have the
default now we have the new message
again this might seem like um extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
reducer all right
so make sure we saved all our files
which we have
and now let's
go ahead so we have
let's just inspect everything it's all
looking good
all right now terminal window we're
going to do npm start
let's see what happens and our web
browser should load up
oh we have an error that's good so now
we're learning stuff
so this again this is all part of your
standard coding is just
hunting down errors in your code so
let's go to index.js
and looks like
we're going to pull in here so we have
reduce
and this should actually be spelled
correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back recompile
let's rerun our
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying mainstream
provider
store
is referenced correctly
okay let's re-run our application
and there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our
applications different objects we're
able to change the messages after you
click
and it's able to then create the new
message again this is a very simple
application but you can see how for
more complex solutions how this becomes
useful and you start using the different
components you create
for your whole solution and that's our
demo
so thank you hopefully you learned a lot
working with redux with
react um we encourage you that if you
like this video to hit the subscribe
button we're generating content like
this all the time and want to make sure
that you get that content
if you really liked this then please
consider
hitting the like button below that
really helps
when working with the youtube algorithms
to make sure that our
videos come up higher and then finally
if you have any questions
please don't hesitate to post in the
questions area in the comments area
below
we do read all of them and we do respond
to as many as we can
thanks and have a great day
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here